good morning everyone
let me introduce who we have with us
today from my far right we have Jim
Alaris was the president of Empire
College who I've worked with for many
years and be very helpful here on this
mission our Commissioner of health dr.
Howard zuker to my left is General
Patrick Murphy while say Morris more
about to say in a moment and to his left
is general raymond shields thank you for
being here today this is an amazing
accomplishment
it's transformative in just one week the
Javits Center looks entirely different
this is a place that's literally going
to save lives let me go through some
facts if I can on a daily update of
where we are and then I want to make
some comments to all the women and men
who are assembled and did such a great
job on this facility the increase in the
number of cases continues we still see
that trajectory going up those are the
dates from March 3rd to March 25th
strategy plan of action all along
step one flatten the curve step to
increase Hospital capacity flatten the
curve meaning the if you do it as well
as you can do it hopefully there is no
high point of the curve there is no apex
it's a flatter lower curve why so the
hospital capacity can keep up with it
that's what this is all about not
overwhelming Hospital capacity and at
the same time increasing the hospital
capacity that we have so if it does
exceed those numbers which it will and
most probability that we have the
additional capacity to deal with it
flattening the curve these are all sorts
of measures that we put in place
are non-essential workers social
distancing closing bars closing
restaurants all the things I did that
made people very happy with me but the
way you make a decision is the benefit
in the burden right the risk and the
reward we are battling a deadly virus is
there an intrusion on daily life yes
is there an intrusion on movement yes
is there an intrusion on the economy yes
but what's on the others other side of
the scale is literally saving lives and
that's not rhetorical that's not drama
that's fact public education is very
important it's important to all of us on
the other side of the balance beam is
public health I decided to close the
public schools because I believed it was
safer to close the schools and reduce
the spread we did that on March 18th we
said we would do it for two weeks and
then we would reassess the situation at
the end of two weeks two weeks ends on
April 1 we also said that we would waive
what's called a 180 day requirement that
every school has to teach for 180 days
we would waive that but that we would
close the schools until April 1 and then
we would reassess also we said that
every school district before it closes
had to come up with plans to continue
functions that they were doing because
school districts do more than just
educate they provide childcare for
essential workers they provide schools
they provide meals in the schools so
everything that they were doing they had
to come up with a plan to mitigate the
consequence of their closing including
distance learning for their students I
have to reassess because April 1 is just
in a couple of days
and I believe the schools should remain
closed I don't do this
joyfully but I think when you look at
where we are and you look at the number
of cases still increasing it only makes
sense to keep the schools closed they
have to continue the programs they're
doing they have to continue the
childcare continue the meals continue
the distance learning programs I'll
continue the waiver on what's called a
180 day mandate that they have to be in
operation but we're going to close the
schools for another two weeks and then
we'll reassess at that point and that is
statewide at the same time we're working
to increase Hospital capacity what is
the possible apex of the curve it
changes a little bit depending on the
day to day to day data day to day but
now we're looking at about 21 days for a
possible apex so we want to do
everything we can to be ready for that
increased capacity that could hit us in
21 days and ramp up the hospital
capacity we are doing everything we can
we're doing things that have never been
done before we're doing things that when
we put them on the table people thought
they were impossible but we are now
doing the impossible as you know well
here with what you did over the past
week all hospitals have to increase
their capacity by 50% we're asking
hospitals to try to increase their
capacity 100% because we need that many
beds we're also looking at converting
dorms we're looking at converting hotels
we've been gathering equipment from
everywhere we can PPE equipment most
important piece of equipment for us a
ventilators and we're shopping literally
around the globe to put put it all in
place we're creating a stockpile of this
equipment so that when and if the apex
hits we can deploy equipment from the
stockpile to whatever region
of the state or whatever hospital needs
it so we collect it we hold it as a
hospital needs it a region needs it then
we deploy it the n95 mask surgical masks
examination gloves protective gowns
coveralls and most importantly the
ventilators why ventilators because this
is a respiratory illness people need
ventilators who come in for acute care
and the people are on ventilators much
longer than most patients are on
ventilators most people are on a
ventilator for two three four days these
kovat patients can come in and need a
ventilator for up to 20 days so you see
why that need for ventilators is so
important and again all of this is to
make sure we're ready for that apex when
the entire system is stressed and under
pressure and that's what we're working
on for the hospital capacity at the
quote-unquote apex we need a hundred and
forty thousand beds we have 53,000 beds
that's why we're scrambling and that's
why we're asking you to do as much work
as you are doing we need 40,000 ICU beds
the ICU beds are the intensive care unit
beds they have ventilators we have when
we started 3,000 ICU beds with 3,000
ventilators so you see how monumental
the tasks are monumental the mountain
that we have to climb of the 140,000 how
do we get to the 140,000 as I said all
hospitals increased by 50%
some hospitals will increase 100 percent
they're gonna get the gold star Hospital
award I don't know exactly what that
means but we'll figure it out later
FEMA and the Army Corps and the National
Guard have been working to put up these
emergency hospitals so far we have
planned for for the one we're in today
at the Javits Center one in Westchester
County Center one at Stony Brook and one
at Old Westbury that would be 4,000
additional units they are all under way
as we speak not as far as long as your
good work at Javits but they are on
their way again with all of these beds
we still have a shortfall so we're going
to go to plan B what's plan B we're
going to seek to build another for
temporary emergency hospitals which will
get us another 4,000 beds and we just
have been scouting sites for a few days
we have settled on a few sites working
with the Army Corps of Engineers and I'm
gonna ask the president today if he will
authorize another for temporary
hospitals for us I want to have one in
every borough and when I have one for
the Bronx Queens Manhattan Staten Island
Brooklyn one for Nassau one for Suffolk
one for Westchester so everybody knows
downstate which is where the essence of
the density is right now that everyone
equally is being helped and is being
protected we look at a site in the Bronx
at the New York Expo Center it's a 90
thousand square foot site seeing what we
did here we think it would work very
well and again the Army Corps of
Engineers has worked with us and looked
at all these sites and things that these
sites work one in Queens at the Aqueduct
Racetrack site 100,000 square feet there
one in Brooklyn and what's called the
Brooklyn cruise terminal it's owned by
the Port Authority but it's a wide open
space
we can convert it very easily 182
thousand square feet and in Staten
Island the College of Staten Island
which is a CUNY facility 77,000 square
feet again inside can be converted it
has power it has
climate control etc we would do the same
thing that we've done here successfully
so we know it works we know it's
feasible building the interior space we
have exterior space that we could put up
a temporary tent for supplies equipment
etc that would give us coverage all
across the downstate area with proximate
facilities to every location downstate
and frankly is the best plan that we can
put together and execute in this
timeline we also have beyond the next
phase of temporary hospitals if the
White House grants that request we have
the Navy ship Comfort coming up that is
going to be on its way soon it's going
to be right here in New York Harbor it
is a massive facility in and of itself
1,000 beds 1,200 medical personnel 12
operating rooms that as a pharmacy it is
a laboratory and it should be here on
Monday so that will also help us in this
quest and then we're looking at
dormitories and converting dormitories
down State we're looking at city college
dormitories Queens College we have the
dormitories because the colleges are
closed and the students have left so we
actually have dormitories that we can
convert we're also looking at hotels and
nursing homes we're looking at the Mary
at Brooklyn Bridge Hotel and a nursing
home called Brooklyn Center
so as you can see we're looking far and
wide
very creative aggressive and finding all
the space that we can possibly find and
converting it to be ready in case we
have that overflow capacity we also have
it planned out so that this will be
coming online before we think the apex
hits and at the same time we're trying
to flatten the curve to delay and soften
that apex right those are the two
strategies slow the spread flatten the
curve in the meantime increase the
hospital capacity so whatever that surge
is that you have you actually have the
capacity to deal with it and right now
we have a plan where over the next three
or four weeks which is same timeline as
the apex possibly coming we're going to
have the capacity as high as we can
possibly get that get the capacity in
terms of where we are today because
we're tracking the numbers we want to
see what's happening and are we getting
closer to the apex are we succeeding in
flattening the curve we've been testing
we test more in this state than any
state in the United States we test more
per capita than China or South Korea so
we ramped up very quickly on the testing
new test 16,000 total tested 138
thousand number of positive cases total
cases forty-four thousand new cases 7377
it continues to spread it all across the
state as it continues to spread all
across the country the number of deaths
were up to 519 in New York that's up
from 385 that is going to continue to go
up
and that is the worst news that I could
possibly tell the people of the state of
New York the reason why the number is
going up is because some people came
into the hospital 20 days 25 days ago
and have been on a ventilator for that
long a period of time the longer you are
on a ventilator the less likely you're
going to you're going to come off that
ventilator and that's not just true with
this virus that's true with every
illness when somebody's on that
ventilator for a prolonged period of
time the outcome is usually not good so
we're seeing a significant increase in
deaths because the length of time people
are on the ventilator is increasing and
the more it increases the higher the
level of deaths will increase and again
we expect that to continue to increase
it's it's bad news
it's tragic news it's the worst news but
it is not unexpected news either if you
talk to any health care professional
they'll tell you about if you're talking
about a loved one if they're not off
that ventilator in a relatively short
period of time it's not a good sign
overall 44,000 people have tested
positive 6000 currently hospitalized
1,500 in intensive care units that's up
290 those are the people who need the
ventilators 2,000 patients have been
discharged that's up 528 so your people
coming into the hospital getting
treatment and leaving the hospital most
people who get the virus will never even
go into the hospital in the first place
right so we have to keep this in focus
80% of the people who get the virus will
what they call self resolved
you'll feel ill maybe you won't feel
that ill you
you have the flu and you self resolved
80% of the people 20% will go into a
hospital some of them will get
short-term treatment and then they go
home a very small percent and they tend
to be all the people more vulnerable
people people with an underlying illness
this respiratory illness compounds the
problem they have they had a compromised
immune system they were fighting
emphysema they were battling cancer and
on top of that they now get pneumonia
which is what this corona virus is
that's the population that is most
vulnerable they then go on to a
ventilator some percentage get off
quickly some percentage don't get off
the longer they're on the higher the
mortality rate New York is still by far
the most affected state both in terms of
number of cases and in terms of number
of deaths why because we welcome people
here from all over the globe so
travelers came here people from China
came here people from Korea came here
people who are travelling around the
country and stopped in China and stopped
in South Korea and stopped in Italy came
here and because we are a very dense
environment you know social distancing
stay six feet away that's hard in New
York City right walk down the sidewalk
and tell me that you can stay six feet
away from someone
we're so dense we're so together which
is what makes us special gives us that
New York energy gives us that New York
mojo it also that density becomes the
enemy in a situation like this this is
the total number of people who have been
hospitalized
and we've been watching these numbers
every day we are now compiling the
numbers I think in what's a smarter way
before we were getting individual
patient data every Hospital how to tell
us about each individual patient what
their address was where they came from
what the underlying illness was and they
had to put all that information together
which was very labor intensive so it was
erratic the way the information would
come in sometimes the hospital was just
too busy to put all that information
together so they didn't send it in until
the next day or the day after this is a
more uniform set of data this is all the
number of people in that house the
entire number of people in that hospital
who have the kovat virus without getting
into all the specifics of individual
names and individual circumstances so
it's it's easier for them to get us this
data and you see again the steady
incline in the number but and this is
good news
early on you see that the number was
doubling every two-and-a-half days then
it was doubling every three days now
it's doubling about every four days it's
still doubling and that's still bad news
because it still means you're moving up
towards an apex right because that
number still goes up but there is good
news in that the rate of the increase is
slowing so they're two separate facts
the rate of the increase is slowing but
the number of cases are still going up
all right and and those two points are
consistent and that's what we're seeing
we want to see the rate slowing and then
we want to see the number of actual
cases coming down or flattening
that's the flattening of the curve but
this is where we are today again to keep
it all in perspective people don't know
what to make of the coronavirus what's
going to happen what's going to happen
Johns Hopkins is studied every
coronavirus since China five hundred and
forty two thousand cases they've studied
of all those cases they've been twenty
four thousand deaths that's a lot of
deaths yes but compared to five hundred
and forty two thousand cases it gives
you a sense of the lethality of this
disease and if you look at the twenty
four thousand they're going to be
overwhelmingly older people vulnerable
people people with underlying illnesses
etc the amount of support that we have
gotten from New Yorkers in the midst of
this crisis is just extraordinary I am a
born in bred New Yorker if you can't
tell my Queens accent I can tell you a
Bronx accent and your Brooklyn accent
your Manhattan accident and your Staten
Island accent but New Yorkers never
cease to amaze me how big their heart is
you know they talk about how New Yorkers
are tough yeah you know we're tough to
live in a place like this you have to be
tough but as tough as we are is as
loving as we are and is as big as our
heart is and when someone needs
something there's no place I'd rather be
than New York and the number of people
who are volunteering who are coming
forward we put out a call for additional
medical personnel because we have to
staff all these additional beds we put
out a call 62,000 volunteers the number
went up ten thousand and one day how
beautiful is that these are people who
are retired
who did their duty who could just sit at
home but they are coming forward same
thing we asked for mental health
professionals who could provide mental
health services electronically over the
telephone through Skype etc many people
are dealing with mental health issues
this is a stressful taxing situation on
everyone on everyone and isolation at
home you are home you're home alone day
after day after day that is a stressful
situation you don't know what's going on
you're afraid you're afraid to go out
you're isolated with your family that's
a stressful situation not that we don't
love to be with our family you all do
but that can create stress and there's
no place to go there's no one to talk to
about that so this mental health service
over the telephone is very very
important I want to speak to the most
important people in the room for a
moment for the people who are
responsible for this great construction
behind me first I'd like to introduce
general Patrick Murphy who's to my left
general Murphy is tested smart and he
has tested tough I've been with a
general for nine years I've seen him in
hurricanes and superstorm sandy and
floods and everything mother nature
could could throw out us I saw I've seen
him in attempted terrorist attacks there
is no one better
he leads from the front he knows what
he's doing
and you could not have a better
commander at this time than General
Patrick Murphy and I want you to know
that
I want to congratulate the Army Corps of
Engineers for what they did here I used
to be in the federal government I worked
with the Army Corps of Engineers all
across the country I worked with them on
the Pine Ridge Indian Reservation
building housing and one of the officers
of the Army Corps of Engineers is still
in service and reminded me of that they
are top-shelf and what they did here is
top-shelf I want to thank the Javits
staff which has really stepped up and I
want to thank our National Guard because
you are the best of us you are the best
of us and whenever we call on you you
were there and what you did in this
facility in one week creating a hospital
is just incredible I don't know how you
did it now you did such a good job that
I'm asking for for more from the
president that's the downside of being
as as good as you are at what you did
but what you did is really incredible
and I want to make two points to you and
I want to make two promises to you this
is a different beast that we're dealing
with this is an invisible beast it is an
insidious beast this is not going to be
a short deployment this is not going to
be that you go out there for a few days
we work hard and we go home this is
going to be weeks and weeks and weeks
this is going to be a long day and it's
going to be a hard day and it's going to
be an ugly day and it's going to be a
sad day this is a rescue mission that
you're on the mission is to save lives
that's what you're doing
the rescue mission is to save lives and
as hard as we work we're not going to be
able to save everyone and what's even
more cruel is this enemy doesn't attack
the strongest of us it attacks the
weakest of us it attacks our most
vulnerable which makes it even worse in
many ways because these are the people
that every instinct tells us we're
supposed to protect these are our
parents and our grandparents these are
our aunts our uncle's these are a
relative who was sick and every instinct
says protect them help them because they
need us and those are the exact people
that this enemy attacks every time I've
called out the National Guard I've said
the same thing to you I promise you I
will not ask you to do anything that I
will not do myself and I'll never ask
you to go anywhere that I won't go
myself
and the same is true here we're going to
do this and we're going to do this
together
my second point is you are living a
moment in history this is going to be
one of those moments they're going to
write about and they're going to talk
about for generations this is a moment
that is going to change this nation this
is an eighth a moment that forges
character forges people changes people
make them stronger make them weaker but
this is a moment that will change
character and ten years from now you'll
be talking about today
to your children or your grandchildren
and you will shut it here because you
will remember the lives lost and you'll
remember the faces and you'll remember
the names and you'll remember how hard
we worked and that we still lost loved
ones and you'll shed a tear and you
should because it will be sad but you
will also be proud you'll be proud of
what you did you'll be proud that you
showed up you showed up when other
people played it safe you had the
courage to show up and you had the skill
and the professionalism to make a
difference and save lives that's what
you will have done and at the end of the
day nobody can ask anything more from
you that is your duty to do what you can
when you can and you will have shown
skill and courage and talent you'll be
there with your mind you'll be there
with your heart and you'll serve with
honor and that will give you pride and
you should be proud I know that I am
proud of you and every time the National
Guard has been called out they have made
every New Yorker proud and I am proud to
be with you yet again and I'm proud to
fight this fight with you and I bring
you thanks from all New Yorkers who are
just so appreciative
of the sacrifice that you are making the
skill that you are bringing the talent
that you're bringing and you give many
New Yorkers confidence so I say my
friends that we go out there today and
we kick coronavirus ass that's what I
say and we're going to save lives and
New York is going to thank you god bless
each and every one of you
the question was who couldn't hurt here
let me paraphrase it the way I want to
paraphrase because I want to answer this
question we've been doing what I've been
doing long enough to learn but just
answer the question we want to answer
the facts okay Zach somebody said on one
of the cable news shows the ventilators
that New York needed aren't even being
deployed they're in a stock pot yes
they're in a stock pile because that's
where they're supposed to be because we
don't need them yet we need them for the
apex the apex isn't here so we're
gathering them in the stock pile so when
we need them they will be there we don't
need them today because we're not at
capacity today that's why they're not
deployed because they're not needed
second point well maybe you don't need
30,000 well look I don't have a crystal
ball everybody's entitled to their own
opinion but I don't operate here on
opinion I operate on facts and on data
and on numbers and on projections we
have Cornell Weill which is making
projections the CDC is making
projections McKinsey and company are
making projections for us all the
projections say you could have an apex
needing 140,000 beds and about 40,000
ventilators those are numbers exact not
I feel I think I believe I want to
believe make the decisions based on the
data and the science and we're following
the data and the science and that's what
the data and the science says I hope we
don't need 30,000 ventilators I hope
some natural weather change happens
overnight and kills the virus globally
that's what I hope
but that's my hope it's my emotion
that's my thought the numbers say you
may need 30,000
you will see as these numbers increase
you'll see hospitals reaching capacity
you'll see if the numbers continue to
increase hospitals over capacity that's
this whole planning exercise that's why
we just are building a thousand bed
facility here that's why we're building
three other 1000 bed facilities that's
why I'm asking the president for another
four thousand bed facility because those
hospitals will reach capacity so to be
alarmed well the hospital is reaching
capacity yeah that's what we've been
saying that's what we've been planning
for that's why we're here
what I said is initially when I closed
the schools I said let's do it for two
weeks and see where we are at the end of
two weeks two weeks is up
I said let's extend it another two weeks
and see where we are and at the end of
two weeks if the same trajectory is
going up and there hasn't been a change
then you're right
then we'll extend it why not say today
we're going to extend it for four weeks
or six weeks or eight weeks because I
don't know what's going to happen I
don't know what's going to happen next
week nobody knows what's going to happen
next week so two weeks and then we'll
reassess but you're either either if if
the numbers continue this way then yes
in all likelihood we'll extend it
another two weeks
the last dr. Zucker but look flatten the
curve there's only two things you can do
right life is options one social
distancing which we have taken as
dramatic in action as anyone anywhere to
testing to find the positive isolate the
positive stop the spread we're doing
more testing than any place in the
country and per capita more than any
place in the globe so we're doing
everything we can
is that why the curve is is slowing or
the doubling is slowing I would think
there's a correlation I don't think it's
a coincidence and the rate of doubling
is slowing and that's the good news
but the curve is still going up doctor
do you want it I concur with what the
governor is saying there's a lot of
different factors that can be involved
in this obviously obviously the social
distancing is I believe working and the
virus is not spreading to more
individuals as we else is spreading but
it's not ending up where the numbers of
hospitalizations keep rising and a
doubling rate as it was earlier so I
think that we'll have a better answer to
this and probably in in a couple more
days when we see the trend
starting with the lessons I'm really
multifaceted
first since I remember the last one yes
the the criteria you need a large open
indoor space with power with HVAC with a
companying space where you can set up
medical staff supplies a staging area
you need a place that's now empty so you
don't have to clear it and my strategic
decision was one per county so every
county every borough has one facility in
their borough and we started we looked
at about 10 sites and we eliminated them
we got them down to a shortlist we went
with the Army Corps of Engineers because
they would actually do the construction
of it and we came up with a final list
of these four I'm today going to send
that list
to the president ask him to approve
those four that would be an additional
4,000 units we have 4,000 units on the
table this is 1000 of those 4,000 so be
a total of 8,000 units from the feds
federal government for temporary
hospital beds
[Music]
well the first step is the approval so
we need the approval first and then the
timeline to get them constructed is
somewhere in the neighborhood of 10 days
but the first question is the approval
that's up to the president
so we are looking at that policy and
recognizing this is that difficult for
many families via hospitals we are
trying to figure out what would be the
approach that we would have with this
but the hospitals have there or have the
rights to the right to do something
further than we would recommend
so we're working closely with all the
hospitals the health care workers are on
the front line as the governor has
mentioned before and we are addressing
what the necessary both proportions
which were working with them but also to
provide information to their patients
and they have been very responsive and
obviously they're concerned about their
patients
the yes do the budgeting discussions
with the legislative leaders the federal
government said promised implied stated
that they would provide aid to state
governments they passed the bill that
didn't do that you know this is math at
one point the we have no state revenues
to speak of we're going to have to
dramatically cut our state expenses you
can't spend that which you don't have
you can't do that in the family you
can't do that in the business you can't
do that in government the federal
government only gave us five billion
dollars that's only for coronavirus
expenses that's all it can be used for
we've lost about ten to fifteen billion
dollars in revenue people don't work
they don't pay income tax businesses
closed they don't pay tax so we have
about a 10 to 15 billion dollar hole
federal government gave us zero nada
niente
zilch we're going to have to cut that's
all New York terms right we're gonna
have to cut education aid because that's
the number one expense and healthcare we
can use the five billion from the feds
for the coronavirus care but the main
expense for the state budget is
education they know that so when they
didn't give the state funding all they
did was cut the education budget to the
state of New York which is a tragedy
[Music]
I'm both there's not a lot to negotiate
you know when it's when the number is
zero it makes it an easy budget to
negotiate so zero is actually an easy
number
executive order four I'm sorry to freeze
grunts we have said there would be no
evictions for there can be no evictions
based on rent for 90 days so if you
don't pay rent for 90 days you cannot be
evicted
yeah that's exactly what we did
yesterday question was closing down
construction sites we're closing down
non-essential construction sites some
construction is essential right to keep
the keep the place running
but non-essential construction is going
to be stopped we have a list I can get
it to you later
you know it is
what I sunned what's called an executive
order I don't know how to call ready to
do in a situation like this people are
out of work you're out of work you can
qualify for unemployment insurance
that's not what you were making you
still have to buy food you still have to
pay expenses rent which tends to be 4050
percent of a person's income believe it
or not becomes a very big expense to
carry I signed an executive order saying
for the next three months
a landlord by law cannot evict a tenant
for non-payment of rent so if you can't
pay the rent that's an understandable
circumstance we've said 90 days because
we don't know how long this is going to
go on we could always revisit it but for
now for 90 days by law the landlord
cannot evict you all let's go to work
guys thank you all very much just give
them a big round of applause for what
they've done and what they're doing
[Applause]
you